[Music]
no kids
allowed on the beach
oh no we never leave each other nothing
separates us are we there yet
you said five minutes technically it's
been more than five minutes
let's just all start slowing down
you believe i found this online i guess
it's not that secret of beast
who would leave this from the hotel
they're so rusted
what's happening found stuff from the
hotel in the sun
what happened to her mom i don't know
what happened to her body has decomposed
how quickly can that happen seven years
but she just died
wait where are the kids kara come here
hey have you seen my children mom i'm
i'm right here
dad why are you looking at me like that
what's happening to us
my daughter just turned six two weeks
ago
whatever is happening to us is happening
very fast you have wrinkles
there's something wrong with this speech
what's happening
people are blacking out going this way
if she makes it to the ledge she might
have a chance why is she stopping
what's she stopping can i wake up wake
up
[Music]
you have to know what this place does i
don't know you're a liar look
what is that a message we never leave
each other
nothing separates us we're connected to
something bigger
oh no we're here for a reason
[Music]
you